one thing you'd love about davey garcia
is his presence and style on the mound
wheeling and dealing challenging hitters
right and left
biggio is ready
as bisho down on strikes one and two
on travis shaw strike three what a
terrific first inning
in this quote-unquote very big game
night start of the season for
taiwan walker when he throws more
strikes with his fastball in qatar
then his changeup becomes a very good
weapon for him
erin hicks hitting just 208 on the
season
curveball and he gets him and what a
good start for walker three up three
down
here's vladimir guerrero jr and he's
down to 241 as you can see did not have
a great
home stand in buffalo and four for 22
during the week
and a fly ball to right center field he
got a lot of this one and he got it all
first pitch and an opposite field home
run for guerrero
and the blue jays have the lead well how
about that that's
impressive and what i like about it is
guerrilla didn't try to muscle it out of
the ballpark he took that fastball away
in his previous times facing davey
garcia he had
two one pitch at bats and this
is a one pitch at bat that gives abu
jays the lead well jean carlos stanton
is back and he will lead off
just makes it a much tougher chore to
get through that lineup once and twice
and three times for starting pitchers
and a playoff push
shattered bat a ground ball to bjo
stan running well gets gunned down at
first one away line drive
down the left field line it is a base
hit
it'll go up against the wall and
urchiller
who has missed 11 games with a bone spur
in his right elbow picks it up where he
left off with a double
and the yanks have first and third one
out and here is brett gardner
that one's driven into right center
field and
he can't make that play as it goes up
against the wall
ershela scores moving to second
is frazier and gardner i guess they're
gonna call that a single
but the game is tied at one so here's
tyler wade
line drive to right field that is a base
hit in front of fischer
scoring is fraser it's an rbi single for
wade
and the yankees lead two to one now the
lineup will roll back over with le
mayhew leading off
hit on the ground in the hole there's a
base head to right field
here's gardner scoring wade heads toward
third
and an rbi by dj as he hits one into
that first base hole
and the yankees take a 3-1 lead so
here's luke voight
that one is driven to left field and
deep going back guriel
turning looking see ya a
long home run into the bleachers by luke
boyd
a three-run shot and it is 6-1
yankees some things in 2020 don't change
and luke floyd is
one of them his 17th home run and hit
the 40 rbi mark
about still rolling out there michael
look at that
now here's aaron hicks and there goes
the right
that ball is high it is far it is gone
in the second deck in fact halfway
back in the second deck hicks
hits one to the sticks and hicks and
voigt
go back to back and belly to belly
and the yankees have scored seven in the
inning and have a 7-1 lead
so bases are loaded no one out two runs
are in
and no one's going to get yamaguchi he
has to take one for the team the yankees
now
have a 9-1 lead and here is le mayhew
pitch hit on the ground fair over third
down the left-field line
rolling to the left-field corner gardner
has scored sanchez has scored
wade has scored holding at second lemayo
with a three-run double five runs are in
in the inning and the yankees have a
12-1
lead very high on davey garcia the
rookie just in his fourth major league
start he's only five
nine one sixty three batters lure to
scoriel he swings at the first pitch
hits it to deep left field and it's gone
a clothesline into the second row
in left field lourdes guriel jr doesn't
wait around
he hits his eighth home run of the
season he and guerrero
both two for two with a homer tonight
the blue jays cut into that big yankees
lead
they now trail 12 to 3. he's going to go
to anthony k
who takes over a first and second nobody
out situation
that one's driven deep to left field
there it goes
sia a three-run home run off the bat of
sanchez
and it's 15 to three yankees bottom of
the sixth
16 to three yanks here is luke voight
and he rips one to left field and that
ball
is gone over the left field wall
urielle turned to play it off the
auxiliary scoreboard
it went over the scoreboard so voight
hits his second home run
of the night and the yankees have a 17-3
lead
garcia is still out there and leading
off the uh the blue jays
is derrick fisher strike three fisher
down looking
left-handed in kevin biggio
and here's beau buchet hit sharply oh
picked beautifully by urshella
and a 1-2-3 inning for davey garcia
rochelle putting on a show at third base
today
and making it look easy so two and two
on frasier with estrada leading off
first
fly ball right field fischer back he's
on the track he's at the wall
see ya a two run home run for frasier
and it's 19-3 yankees well here
is le mayhew the pitch dude dj
and that ball is gone into the left
field seats
it's 20 to three yankees and they have
hit
two three four five the yanks have been
six homers tonight